Alright. We'll do one last one here.
-Alright. Great. -Alright. Here we go.
We'll do one last one here. It's from Sarah Munson.
"Hey, Jimmy, I'm a big fan of Ford trucks,
and I especially love
their all-new F-Series Super Duty pickup truck."
It's awesome. Work hard, play hard.
The problem is, I love trivia games that involve a giant pie
made of whipped cream being launched
at someone from a catapult.
Is there any way you can combine those things?"
Well, Sarah, you're in luck because...
[ Laughter ] -Wow.
-There's a Ford Super Duty down in the 30 Rock Plaza
with a catapult attached to it
that can launch a giant whipped cream pie through the air.
Let's do this!
Wanna do this? Come on, Higg. Come on, Tariq.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hey, guys, we're down in the 30 Rock Plaza.
Tariq and I are about to play the Ford Mega Pie Challenge.
Higgins, tell us how it works. -Well, the game is simple.
In front of you is a Ford Super Duty
equipped with a whipped-cream catapult.
You'll answer trivia questions
designed to test your knowledge about the Super Duty.
If you guess right, you move on.
If you guess wrong, you must press the cream launcher,
which will randomly trigger the giant pie to be thrown at you.
Alright. Here's your first question.
-I'm a pumpkin hauler myself.
Pumpkins average around 4 pounds per pumpkin.
-Oh, my God. -I'm gonna say my answer is B.
-B. That is correct!
10,000 pumpkins.
Tariq, it's your turn in the cream zone.
And here's your question.
-I'm gonna say "A." I'm gonna say "A."
-"A."
[ Buzzer ] Ooh, sorry.
"C, 360 degrees.
-Oh, great.
You must now press the cream launcher.
-Yeah! Come on! -Which may or may not
trigger the pie to be catapulted unto you.
Good luck. -Good luck, bud.
[ Suspenseful music ]
♪♪
[ Ding ]
-Ohh. -Whew!
-Unbelievable. -Jimmy -- You survived, Tariq.
Jimmy, you're up. Your question is...
-So does the truck have the torque of a truck?
-Does it? That's up to you.
-Trying to trick me, but sure. -You're gonna go "A"?
-Yeah.
[ Buzzer ] -Ooh. Wrong!
It is "B," a semi truck.
Jimmy, press the cream launcher.
Good luck!
[ Suspenseful music ]
♪♪
[ Ding ]
Ohh! You survived.
Tariq, you're up. -Unh!
-I'm gonna go "D," all of the above.
-This is insane. -That is correct! "D." Yes!
Alright, Jimmy, your question. -I know.
[ Laughter ]
-Is it, "A," eggs and toast...
"B," cereal...
"C," steel-cut oatmeal...
or, "D," a raspberry pain au chocolat
with a quiche Lorraine and a warm hazelnut ganache
with a hint of cinnamon? -Hint of cinnamon.
-I am definitely going -- I've been to breakfast with you.
It is "D."
[ Buzzer ] -Oh, no!
Of course, it's "C," steel-cut oatmeal.
Come on, man! Time to press it, baby.
Press the launcher. -Moment of truth.
[ Suspenseful music ]
♪♪
[ Engine revs ]
[ Mozart's "Requiem in D Minor" plays ]
♪♪
[ Applause ]
-Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
-That's all the time we have for Suggestion Box.
Thank you so much to Ford. Really, thank you, Ford.
We'll be right back with more "Tonight Show," everybody.
Oh, my gosh.
-♪ ...my favorite cartoon ♪
♪ After that, there's a honeymoon ♪